good morning john i've had a half a cup
of coffee and i'm gonna do something i
almost never do i'm gonna make an
unscripted video about a thing that i
care very passionately about you
watching this video need to not want a
gas stove why
because they suck here's the thing that
you are right about the curly q heating
element stoves they are the worst
they're hard to clean they're extremely
hard to control like you cannot turn
them on and off quickly they take
forever to heat up they take forever to
cool down what happened is the stove top
and natural gas industry made it so that
what takes the place of that in your
brain is a natural gas stove that has
like the little blue flames they're so
beautiful that like gordon ramsay uses
but what you're doing when you have a
natural gas stove is burning stuff in
your home which results in get this
decreased indoor air quality you can get
around this by like having your fume
hood like going full blast and certainly
never have a natural gas stove that
doesn't have a hood or
get this you could have an induction
stove top that has more power and is
easier to control than natural gas
chances are there are three pipes
connected to your house there's the one
that brings you water that one's
important the one that takes the water
away we also want that and the one that
brings you methane
what century is this it would be like
having the gas station bring the
gasoline directly to your car like this
is a bad idea i know what you're
thinking hank there is no way that
cooking my hello fresh is significantly
adding to climate change and you're
right but here's the thing household
natural gas use is a big contributor to
climate change it's just not mostly the
stovetop however when natural gas
companies ask people how they feel about
switching their furnace from gas to
electric or their water heater from gas
to electric they're like i don't care
whichever whatever's better i don't know
because you currently have a really
efficient way to get power into your
home that isn't a pipe full of methane
it's a power line and there are great
electric water heaters and there are
great electric furnaces and heat bumps
but people say i want my natural gas
stove but that's a tiny percentage of
the methane that is actually being sold
by the gas company almost all of it is
used in furnaces and water heaters but
as long as people are like i want to
keep my gas stove it's harder to clean
it makes the air inside my house dirty
but house hunters says that it's a
top-tier product people will keep having
the natural gas companies build and
replace this extremely expensive
infrastructure to pipe gas into our
homes and gas companies are freaking out
about this and they're doing all these
campaigns about how great gas ranges are
even though they are objectively worse
because if they can keep that toe hole
they can make it make sense to keep
giving you gas for those other things
that electric could easily replace but
look electric could also easily replace
your stove because induction stove tops
are better than gas and so one of the
most important things that you can do as
a person who is concerned about climate
change is take the little thing out of
your brain that says the gas stoves are
the best kind of stove and look at it
and be like you're a freaking idiot then
you throw it onto your induction
stovetop and nothing happens because
that's not how it works it induces the
heat in the pan the stove top itself
doesn't get hot cause they're amazing so
you have to put it into a pan put that
on the stove top fry it up and have it
with butter this is why i script
that right there is why i script so that
doesn't happen it's not important that
you replace your gas stove right now in
fact it's probably best that you don't
it's important that you don't think it's
better than induction because it's not
because at some point in the future
someone's going to knock on your door
and say this area is about to have its
natural gas pipes replaced and we have
to decide whether or not to replace them
with infrastructure that will last 60 to
80 years and if a bunch of people in
your neighborhood say well i would but i
really like my gas stove top it's not
gonna happen and we're gonna keep
burning methane in people's houses for
80 years i would be sympathetic if gas
were better but it's not john i'll see
you on tuesday